wasn't afraid of taking on paraguay's
drug traffickers he led the country's
most important investigations against
organized crime and money laundering
it's a job that came with a lot of risk
and on tuesday he was shot three times
by hitman while honeymooning at a resort
on a colombian island near the coastal
city of cartagena
the killers arrived on jet skis moments
after pitch's wife journalist claudia
aguilera announced on social media they
were expecting a baby
the killing has shocked both colombia
and paraguay
it is very painful very hard i spoke
with colombian president ivan duque on
the phone and he promised me that he
would give us all his support to solve
the case to look for those responsible
i've also spoken with the north american
government about this who will support
us through colombia now i'm going to
visit the attorney general
colombia's national police sent homicide
investigators to cartagena a police
delegation from paraguay will assist the
investigation
we have information that is being
collected in urgent efforts and which is
confidential which will help us to
identify those responsible for this
regrettable occurrence
hours later the police released two
pictures of one of the alleged killers
pitchy was seen as an incorruptible
prosecutor in one of the most corrupt
countries in latin america but his
success in high-profile drug and money
laundering cases brought him powerful
enemies his death shows the reach of
paraguay's drug mafias and their
connections in colombia alessandra piety
al jazeera bogota